Ja das was heute
Am ende passiert ist das ist ein wirklich seltenes ereignis und genau genommen ist es nicht nur ein ereignis es sind gleich drei
außergewöhnliche ereignisse zusammen gekommen eine flut von stream5 ein sichtbarer super mond und zeitgleich auch ein blauer mund dieses
spektakel nennt sich dann super blaublut
Mondfinsternis und das hat es zuletzt vor 150 jahren gegeben was wir der geburt eines schlumpfs zu tun hat von
Wo aus dieses himmelsspektakel von der erde, aus zu sehen war und warum uns dieses phänomen für zukünftige mondmissionen
hilfreich sein kann jetzt den krieg zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Da übrigens auch wieder einen themenvorschlag von whatsapp ganz viele haben da gesagt macht dieses thema
Und hier ist es wenn ihr auch bei whatsapp dabei sein sollte der link ist dann
Am ende des videos und unten in dem video beschreibung ja vielleicht. Habe das mitbekommen
Im januar gab es gleich zwei mal einen vollmond dieses phänomen wird auch blaue und genannt und ist schon ziemlich
außergewöhnlich wohl deswegen gibt es eine englische sprache auf das sprichwort once
Im blumenmeer damals die fernsehserien die schlümpfe gesehen hat weiß jetzt auch dass ein
Schlumpf vielleicht jetzt auf die welt kommt und ja der mond steht der erde gerade besonders nahe
Er erscheint viel größer am himmel und so kamen zum vollmond auch noch das phänomen des super mondes dazu das ist gerade am frühen nachmittag
europäischer zeit passiert genau wie übrigens bereits
Am dritten dezember und auch schon anfang januar der mond also ist also der erde ungewöhnlich nah gekommen
364.000 kilometer haben uns getrennt nur damit das besser euch vorstellen können die mittlere entfernung liegt bei 384 1000 km
Langfristig wird solch einem zweier day zwischen mond und erde immer seltener vorkommen denn die bahn des mondes entfernt sich jedes jahr um etwa
3,8 zentimeter von der erde
Jedenfalls steht fest dass die gemessenen helligkeit des mondes bei solch einem super mond um etwa 30 prozent größer ist
Als bei der durchschnittlichen entfernung als würde das nicht reichen hat sich zudem
Super und blauen vollmond auch noch etwas rot dazu gemischt denn in der selben nacht gab
Es jetzt also ich jetzt also bei uns am tag gab es laut us raumfahrtbehörde nasa auch eben eine totale mondfinsternis
der mond scheint
Michael roth und wird in diesem zustand als blutmond
Bezeichnen der grund die erde schiebt sich zwischen mond und sonne und wirft ihren schatten auf dem mond später verdeckt ziehen ganz die erde
Schont also die sonnenstrahlen ab doch einige werden von der erdatmosphäre gebrochen und zum mond geworfen dies sind langweilige
infrarotstrahlen die den mond in die geheimnisvolle gestalt
des blut mondes hüllen
Genauso übrigens wie beim sonnenauf- und -untergang dann wird das licht der sonne ja auch rot etwas korrekter als die bezeichnung
mondfinsternis wäre also
So etwas wie mond rettung der begriff blutmond deutet es ja schon an für die nasa war das ereignis übrigens jetzt ganz besonders spannend denn
Diese mondfinsternis bietet die möglichkeit
Zu erforschen was passiert wenn die mondoberfläche sehr schnell abkühlt dadurch wollen die nasa wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler neue erkenntnisse
zum sogenannten
Regolith also dem locker material gewinnen das ist grob gesagt das gemisch von
Lockerem gestein und boden auf der mondoberfläche dazu einer der beteiligten, wissenschaftler
Noah pedro von der nasa während einer mondfinsternis ist der wechsel der temperatur, so krass dass es
So aussieht als würde die mondoberfläche von einem ofen zu einem gefrierschrank
Übergehen und das innerhalb weniger stunden das war sein team hat das himmelsphänomen vom haller karla
observatorium auf der insel maui hawaii beobachtet
zitat der ganze charakter des mondes verändert sich wenn wir ihnen während einer finsternis mit einer wärmebildkamera beobachten
Im dunkeln können viele vertraute krater und andere merkmale nicht gesehen werden und die normalerweise
unscheinbaren bereiche um einige kracher beginnen zu blühen weil die felsen dort noch warm sind ja das sagt der weltraum physiker paul hey
In welchem tempo die oberfläche wärme verliert hängt von der größe des gesteins und auch der
Materialeigenschaft ab je nachdem die porös ist beispielsweise ist diese informationen über die geologische beschaffenheit des mondes die können jetzt
Zb genutzt werden, um geeignete landeplätze
für zukünftige mondmissionen zu identifizieren wir in europa konnten das
ereignis nur indirekt über das internet beobachten die drei himmelsereignis waren lediglich in neuseeland australien ostasien
Im westen von nordamerika perfekt zu beobachten und zwar mit bloßem auge
Im gegensatz zur sonnenfinsternis ist das nämlich dann möglich übrigens die nächste mondfinsternis wird es berechnungen zufolge wohnt am
27 juli dieses jahres geben ein kleines geburtstagsgeschenk für mich und die wird dann auch
Aus europa zu sehen sein wenn das wetter mitspielt
Im sommer wird der mond allerdings sehr klein sein und auch der termin für den nächsten super blaublut und der steht schon fest
Astronomie teams haben ihn auf den 31 januar
2037 datierten mal sehen ob wir dann auch hier in europa live sehen können wenn ihr die berichten dann
2037 pixum als erste sehen wollt dann meldet euch hier bei whatsapp an dann erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt in der redaktion vom krieg zum mitmachen und themen vorschlagen oder fragen zu videos stellen
der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken
Und natürlich nicht das abo mit der glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
Helium-3 abbau auf dem mond china als erster ansonsten bis dann
flattern